I bought something from you last week, and I'm very disappointed.
Oh yeah? What's the problem?
Yeah. Well, my blackberry is not working.
What's the matter? You've run out of juice?
No! No! It's completely frozen!
What day are you going to get my blackberry working?
Well, could be an application issue. Where'd you install that blackberry?
It was on my desktop.
You might want to launch the blackberry from the desktop.
Well, I've already tried that a few times, I mean, all it did was mess up windows.
Well, it might be worth waiting a couple of weeks, they got the latest blackberries coming in then.
Could you give me a date?
Certainly.
Let me put that date in my diary.
Anything else I can help you with?
Yes, yes, I've also got a problem, to be honest, with my apple.
Oh dear! Oh dear! That is an old apple isn't it?
When did you buy that?
Last week.
Tell you what, let me try booting it.
Now it's crashed.
Oh.
Anything else I can help you with?
Well funny enough, yes. My grandson's birthday is soon, you see.
Now, he's already got an apple, and a blackberry.
I mean, have you got anything else that he might just like?
Well, we're doing a special offer on these. I mean, I can't make a head or tail of them...
...but the kids seem to like them: eggs box 360.